Once leadership,
it's the capacity to see what the hell's
in front of your face and maybe in every
direction and then the capacity to use
your language properly in a
transformative manner and to transform
chaos into order and God only know how
those,
how long it took the Mesopotamians to
figure that out and the best they could
do is dramatize it,
but it's staggeringly brilliant.
No,
it's.
It's by no means obvious and this chaos
is chaos is a very strange thing and
this is the chaos that God wrestled with
at the beginning of time.
Chaos is what?
It's half psychological and half real.
There's no other way to really describe
it.
The chaos is what you encountered when
you're thrown into deep confusion,
right?
When your world falls apart,
when,
when you encounter something that blows
you into pieces,
when your dreams die,
when you're betrayed,
it's the chaos that emerges and the
chaos has everything at once and it's
too much for you and that's for sure,
and it pulls you down into the
underworld and all.
That's where the dragons are and all
you've got at that point is your
capacity to bloody well,
keep your eyes open and to speak as
carefully and clearly as you can and
maybe if you're lucky,
you'll get through it that way and come
out the other side and it's taken people
a very long time to figure that out.